more bad news from the office of
national statistics and inflation
Consumer Price inflation back into the
double digits the highest rate for 40
years we can see it on the charts it's a
sudden recent Spike we know some of
what's been causing that of course it's
the increase of things like housing
costs in particular High Energy prices
that are punishing us all but the
particular cause of this month's bad
news it's food prices nearly 15 percent
month on year-on-year rise in a price of
our shopping baskets so let's look at
Food inflation in more detail we can see
a slightly more wiggly line but again
those same terrifying spikes in the last
few months the highest that it's been
since the early 1980s what's
particularly tough about the food price
story is where it's hitting us it's
hitting us where it hurts most in basic
Staples things like milk baked beans
tinned soup exactly the sort of foods
you you turn to when you're trying to
save a bit of money so not only is food
going up it's going up in a way that
punishes households the worst why well
the short answer is it's to do with the
cost of importing food into this country
Britain depends very heavily on imported
food and what we can see very clearly
here is that a while domestically
produced food has also increased in
price imported Foods whether from the
continent or further afield have
rocketed in price over the past 12
months that really matters to see why it
matters and how much it matters just
look at how much of some of our
foodstuffs this country does import
almost all of our fish Maize vegetable
oils and dairy products very expensive
time of year to be buying the
ingredients for pumpkin pie the better
pumpkin pie than anything with imported
vegetables because things like melons
and Kiwis as well as olive oil and
cheese much higher in price this year
than they were this time last year as
well of course as the ubiquitous lettuce
now this is bad enough how are consumers
responding to it and what more can we do
unsurprisingly one of the things the
households are doing is they're buying
less branded food and substituting it
with own Brand Products typically own
banned products very similar quality
sometimes the same factories produce
them that makes a lot of sense we're
keeping an open mind about wonky fruit
and veg again good idea at these times a
couple of other very practical
suggestions talking to the experts one
shop to a budget and Shop to a list that
helps avoid buying the things that you
don't end up using at the end of the
week number two use Supermarket shopping
apps while you're walking around the
aisles then you'll only put things in
the basket that you know you need and
you keep track of your basket before you
pay for it and three if you're not
already doing it figure out when your
local supermarket marks down at the end
of the day that can often save you 15 20
25 on some of those lines no Magic
Bullets but every little helps